- I got asked out on the job twice,
and it was just a little bit awkward.
- Shoulda said "Yeah,"
coulda got an extra tip.
- Never have I ever eaten
a customer's leftovers.
- For sure.
- Ooh 100%.
- I have not.
- Everyone has.
- I've wanted to.
- Pretend to, like,
push it in the garbage,
and just like, sneak a
couple popcorn shrimp.
- I've even hit a cup of
someone's wine before,
once or twice, come and
bring it to the dish area.
Look around for a little
bit, do a quick uh.
You know what I'm saying?
Then you're back on the floor.
- Makes the job easier.
- Then you gotta look
at the customers, too,
and be like "Would I make out with them?"
And that's a good
judgment of whether or not
I'm gonna eat their food.
- If it's there, I'm eating it.
- Never have I ever dropped
food but still served it.
- Not on the floor
- Ooh.
- I mean, I've dropped a
couple pepperonis before
at a pizza restaurant I
worked at, on the floor,
before it was cooked, and
just picked it back up,
threw it on the thing,
and right back in the oven
- I think that's fine,
the oven kills the germs.
- I was gonna say, right?
- I've done it on the
bench next to the plate.
I don't know if that counts.
- Okay.
- Probably fine.
- Yeah I dropped it on the floor.
- It wasn't like a big
deal, you know what I mean?
It wasn't like on a very
dirty ground or anything.
- I've definitely dropped food before,
and thought about serving it,
but I just seized the
opportunity to eat it myself.
- Oh they were so mean.
The customers were so mean,
and it dropped on the floor
for like three seconds
and I picked it up and
looked at my coworker
and he was like "I didn't see anything"
and I was like "Okay."
- Never have I ever spat
in a customer's food.
- Definitely not.
- I have not.
- I would never do that.
- I've seen it in movies
and it's too much for me.
- No, it's gross.
- Definitely have not.
- Again, but like, really wanted to.
When they're just so rude.
- Oh my God, you have?
- They deserved it.
This lady, she ordered very specifically,
and I got her order 100% right.
She wanted to complain about it,
'cause she wanted her meal for free.
I said, "Ma'am, I wrote
everything down word for word."
She called me a derogatory
name, about my race,
and threw her ice at me.
So, when she got her
correct food this time,
it was a little bit extra correct.
- That's fair then, if they
call you a name, I get that.
- They came at me, they
threw their drink at me so.
- Oh my God.
- What'd you expect?
- Never have I ever lied
about knowing if a dish
had gluten or some other
product in it or not.
- I was still in training and she asked
if the soup was vegan,
and it was tomato soup,
so I took a chance and was
like "Yeah, it's whatever."
It's not.
The stock in the soup is
actually chicken stock,
and it's tomato bisque,
which is 90% cream.
I learned my lesson from that.
- Anything bad happen?
- She's still alive.
- I feel like most people
don't even know what gluten is,
so when they it to me,
I'm like "I don't know."
And they ask me if it
has gluten, it's like,
"Shouldn't you know if a
potato has gluten in it?"
I don't know.
- I have when I was more
ignorant about those things.
'Cause I started working
in the restaurant business
when I was like 16, so I
remember the first time
I got asked that question and I was like,
"I don't know, no there's not."
But then I had a friend
whose mom had Celiac disease
and I very quickly learned,
like, the seriousness of it
and I was like, okay lesson learned,
I will always triple check ingredients.
- Never have I ever given bad service
because I thought they wouldn't tip well.
- I've never given bad service
because I didn't think anybody
was going to be a bad tipper, but I mean,
there's obviously been
times where, you know,
your soul's just not
into it, because you know
they're not going to give you any money.
- I don't know.
- Oh be honest.
- I may have, but I also haven't
because this happens to me
because I'm foreign.
I've noticed that servers
will be really rude to me
from the start, sometimes.
- 'Cause they think, yeah.
- 'Cause they're like, she's
foreign, she's not gonna tip.
I'm like, actually I'm
probably gonna tip better
than everyone else.
- Yeah.
- And I'm always right.
- Yes
- I'm always right.
- Never have I ever messed
up an order on purpose.
- What would the purpose be?
- Yeah, that's what I'm thinking.
What would the purpose of that be?
That's just gonna cause hell.
- Yeah I don't think I have.
- No, definitely a lot by mistake.
- Oh.
- I've never messed it up on purpose.
I think the mistakes come
from just kind of zoning out
and not being focused enough.
- I have definitely messed
up an order on purpose
because I felt the person
was like a mean-ass (bleep).
And I thought it was just funny, like,
someone had a lot of
allergies, supposedly,
like they were gluten free,
they were flour free, I mean,
I worked at a pizza restaurant.
They ended up doing the order wrong,
and just kept bringing it back.
It made me laugh.
- Never have I ever dated a customer.
- Huh?
I've got to think about that one.
I'm going to go with the safe answer here.
- I have not.
I wish I would have.
- No.
- I have not.
- Yeah I have.
- I've had a lot of, have you?
- Yeah, I've worked in bars.
- Okay, see I've never worked in bars
so it was always just breakfast food.
So the type of people
that were asking me out
were like 50 year olds.
- Yeah I've definitely gone out for drinks
with cute guys I've met.
- Hell yeah.
- Never have I ever had sex at work.
- That'd be rather tough.
- Ooh.
- I haven't, but I know people that have.
- I have.
I never thought I would admit that.
It was with an old co-worker,
there was no one around,
if that makes up for it.
- [Camera Man] Was it
in the walk-in freezer?
- No, not in the freezer.
- I'm kind of disappointed
for this, I feel like.
- I know, I really wish
I could flip it around,
I really do.
- Right?
- It's an interesting industry to be in.
It sucks sometimes,
sometimes its wonderful.
I don't want to be cliche,
but sometimes I like to see
the smiles on people's faces.
There are happy people when
you're working in this industry.
Sometimes, sometimes.
- There are definitely
really interesting stories
that can come from customers
who are just a little bit off
or super rude to you.
- You should always be
nice to your servers,
like, they're taking care of your food,
they're working so hard.
- They have power.
- They're also taking
care of six other tables
at the same time.
- Sometimes more.
- Regardless of how much I hated working,
and still hate working in
the restaurant industry,
it's actually kind of fun
and there's a lot of good
stories you can tell.
- I feel like we have
the same general answers
to the questions so no matter
what kind of restaurant
you work at it, I feel like
it's all kind of the same.
(upbeat music)